hello today I wanted to give a quick
look at this paper scaling Transformer
to 1 million tokens and Beyond with rmt
by idar bulletov Yuri kuratov and
Mikhail s boardsef this paper has a big
promise namely scaling Transformer
inference to a humongous 1 million even
2 million tokens and in the first page
plot right here they have some tasks
that they want the Transformer to do for
example there's a memorized task there
is a detect and memorized task and there
is even a reasoning task and as you can
see right here we have input size in
tokens and they go up to 2 million and
you can pretty much see that the
Transformer holds up performing these
tasks across all of those token sizes
now there are a few a few caveats to
this mostly the issue is a little bit in
just in the marketing of the paper the
paper itself is actually pretty good and
pretty okay in fact it's a follow-up to
an earlier paper on this rmt model right
here this uh we're gonna look at that
briefly but the paper is essentially a
small extension to that other paper
namely that other paper did the same
thing for auto regressive so for
causally masked decoder style
Transformers and this one the paper even
says it's not a paper it's a technical
report simply applies the same thing to
encoder Transformers such as Bert and it
actually turns out that this variant
right here is simpler so conceptually
you'd actually read and do this paper
right here first and then do the decoder
only paper because that you know you
have to handle the causal masking we're
going to dive into a little bit of this
but just to take expectations down a
tiny bit this is not this is not the way
to go and scale Transformer to to
ginormous inputs in the way that you
think this is very much we'll get we'll
get into it so there is a there is a
diagram right here that shows about how
this is going to be achieved namely
we're going to we're going to have text
like blah blah blah blah blah really
long sequence of text that doesn't fit
into a Transformer Transformers suffer
from quadratic scaling their attention
mechanism requires huge amounts of
memory that scales quadratically with
input length so if you have a segment
like this and if you want your
Transformer to consume twice as much
tokens uh then you need four times as
much memory four times as many tokens 16
times the amount of memory you quickly
run out of memory so that's why this
paper or this method considers chunking
the text into plug into chunks into
sequences or what they call segments and
then processing each segment with a
Transformer and then somehow connecting
these segments together over inference
this is obviously not the first time we
are seeing something like this also
they themselves say so there have been
previous attempts such as Transformer XL
and various other things Way Way Back in
the Day in like 2020 2019 already that
did an approach like this newer
approaches to extending the sequence
length of Transformers are for example
things like long former big bird and big
bird and so on no big bird not big bird
that do consider the whole sequence but
they do something like they say okay if
we process this token right here we only
do local full attention and then we're
going to do some kind of a sparse
attention to the segments that are sort
of outside of our local segment and then
some special token attention to maybe
like the very first token in the
sequence because that might be more
important or something like this so
everyone's been sort of helping
themselves with getting around this
quadratic attention again this paper
considers chunking the text into
multiple segments so they process each
segment with a Transformer and here
think of Bert think of a task where you
need to input an entire sequence and
then classify that entire sequence in
fact we can go look at the tasks they
consider right now the easiest is a
memory memorize task so the memorize
task consists of text right there is
text text XXX somewhere in the text
there is a fact the fact might be
something like this Daniel went back to
the hallway and then at the very end of
that sequence there is a question so all
in between they just fill in text that's
just noise that's just there to confuse
the model it's just random text you grab
something from Wikipedia just insert it
here
so at the very end there is a question
where is Daniel and the model is
supposed to answer hallway either by
classification or by pointing into some
vocabulary there are various ways to
implement that but you can do it
um with a Transformer like bird okay
this is in essence a sequence
classification task into like a preset
vocabulary so if this here was smaller
than let's say 512 tokens then you could
just feed it into Bert and have Bert
train and answer the thing however if
this is longer than the bird context
size then you need to go to a few tricks
so the memorize tasks considers
obviously
um text that is longer than just one
segment for the purposes of this paper
there's also the detect and memorize a
task which is slightly harder so in the
memorize task you're guaranteed that the
fact is always in the first segment and
in the detect and memorize task the fact
could be anywhere so you also have to
detect where that fact is in any of
these sequences that you need to
remember and then at the end
um at the end answer by the way remember
here is is only technically done in this
you could also like a long form or
something like this would not use memory
but they would simply have or rely on
some sort of attention from the question
to the place where the fact was written
so that's how a normal Transformer would
do it this paper right here will write
something into memory and then consider
that memory in the last segment right
here
there is a reasoning task where it's
even slightly more complicated so there
will be one fact there will be another
fact somewhere in the sequence and you
need to consider both facts in order to
answer the question at the end they do
have examples right here but I think the
example is is kind of wrong so Fact one
would be the hallway is east of the
bathroom facto is the bedroom is west of
the bathroom and the question is what is
the bathroom east of
and the answer is bedroom but I think
like just looking at this I only need
Fact Two to answer that I don't even
need Fact one so maybe this is just kind
of a wonky example that they've tried to
give right here I I don't see how Fact
one is relevant here
um but I trust that the actual data set
this two-way relation uh Babi task
actually has two-way relationship uh
data points okay now that we know what
we're dealing with let's look at how
this model does it so
what we need to do is at least in in
this sense as I said we need to have a
way to carry information over from one
segment to the next segment to the next
segment and so on and they Implement
that by forms of these memory tokens
right here so in a regular Transformer
you simply input your text segment as
tokens so there's going to be token
token token token token token and you
train that using causal uh no no sorry
invert you train that using mask
language modeling or something like this
what they do here is they add a series a
fixed amount of memory tokens let's say
there are eight memory tokens here and
the output obviously is going to be
again the number the number of tokens
right here now whether you train those
or not
um that's up to you I think they start
with a pre-trained bird and
um
they they don't do the masked language
modeling during training of this so they
only fine tune the task but you still it
still output those tokens and you'd also
output eight new or four let's say four
four new memory tokens so four memory
tokens go in four memory tokens uh get
out now these aren't the same tokens but
you just dedicate slots and say these
are the memory tokens of the input and
these are the memory tokens of the
output and you take the memory tokens of
the output and you feed them back into
the input right here and again there is
Transformer layers and you feed there
are output tokens and you take them so
this is how you can store information
let's say there is an important fact
right here in the text
um the Transformer by means of attention
mechanism transforming things across
their layer could use that to store that
fact somehow into these memory tokens
and then in the next segment let's say
there is a question right here that it
needs to answer that this is the final
segment it could consult that memory
together with the questions there could
be cross attention or sorry well that's
technically self-attention there'd be
self-attention into that memory to
retrieve the the fact that was stored
there if this is not the last segment it
could also simply recognize that there
is no fact right here and it could just
pass through the memory tokens to the
output unmodified so you have various
various ways right here notably this is
distinct from something like Transformer
XL or Transformer XL tried to do and for
that I'm going to show you the previous
paper right here the recurrent memory
Transformer paper which was accepted at
nurips in 2022 and you'll immediately
recognize things because it's as I said
this one million tokens paper is our
technical report is just an extension of
this paper right here it's even the same
diagram they actually start with this
and they say oh no we actually need to
make it more complicated because we have
this decoder only Transformers so we
have to have like a read a portion of
the memory and the right portion of the
memory because attention can't go both
ways so if as we produce this segment
right here we need to consult the read
but then we need to write to the right
like we need to produce the right tokens
that we can then pass into the read
tokens of the next segment so it gets
more complicated and after that they go
a step back for this technical report
the Transformer XL what it does is it
simply it simply says hey what we can do
is we can simply take the of this
Transformer layer right here so these
are the different layers of the
Transformer this would be one Yellow
Block in the other diagram of this layer
we're simply going to take the last kind
of hidden state right here like the last
attention I guess key or value query key
and value no key and value pair maybe
we're simply going to take these states
right here and we're going to have this
segment do cross attention into this so
you can always do cross attention into
the previous segment
um attention attention Maps I guess not
maps um States like you can do cross
attention into the previous segments
States
like you would do cross attention in an
encoder decoder way but you simply say
well I do it into the previous segment
so each segment here can technically
look at the intermediate state
of the previous layer and that's how you
achieve sort of a temporal notion but
there is no there is a stop gradient
always because he eventually you're
going to run out of memory because if
you back propagate you need to consider
um you need to keep all of this in
memory and that's why it's simply just
stop grain they say you can attend but
the last segment has no chance of
learning what to effectively store for
the future so memory has two components
one is I'm going to look back into the
past that is trainable in Transformer XL
you train looking back into the past how
you need to do that the other component
is obviously what do I need to store can
I learn to effectively store something
and that Transformer Excel cannot do
because there is no back propagation
through time to teach a previous layer
what to store in its memory output that
the next layer can consider the
recurrent memory Transformer essentially
solves that by doing back propagation
through time now
I can simplify this a little bit by
saying maybe you're confused by you know
what is like the memory is here and here
and there are these memory tokens and so
on just consider this let's say we have
um let's let's consider this uh segment
by segment text segment by text segment
so we have segment one that's the input
text segment and let's say we have like
a a hidden State h0 that's uh M like
let's call that M memory zero we just
initialize that to all zeros that goes
in there's a box this is this could be
anything like any box at all and then
there's going to be an output at this
that this is optional we only really
need the output at the end and
also an output M1 so these two
are outputs
we can have multiple output heads on a
neural network right or we can output
one vector and then split it in the
middle and consider the left hand part
the output and the right hand part the
new memory right the new memory will
then go into the
it will go into
this function so segment 2 gets in here
there is output 2 and there is memory 2
and so on now the catches the weight of
this
and this are obviously shared right this
is always the same function so in effect
the way this looks is it's always the
same box and then there is the segment
of the ith element and then the memory
will always be fed back so the memory of
the if segment will always be get back
and the output of the ith second and
there you have it and we know what this
is we already uh no it's it's like it's
it's an RNN like it's this is just a
recurrent now and they don't make a
secret out of it like the thing is
called recurrent memory mechanism all
that is is an RNN where the part right
here
is a Transformer like that that's it
um
there is the way they arrange the memory
and so on and especially in the previous
paper with the read and write and
whatnot all of that is a technical
detail of how the Transformer Works in
essence this is a recurrent neural
network where the base building block is
a Transformer so this is not scaling
Transformers to 1 million tokens or
anything like this this is an RNN that
has a Transformer as a building block
um I'm not trying to to put this paper
down obviously they are very clear what
they're doing right
um I just feel the community has seen
the title and it's going like
[Music]
um but yeah so considering considering
this why is this a new at I highly doubt
this is a new thing
um and it's maybe just written up
differently the reason something like
Transformer XL hasn't done this because
in Transformer Excel I could just do
back propagation Through Time what they
do in this older paper is they do back
prop through time and now obviously they
can't unroll for thousands and thousands
of segments
you can't do that in an RNN either so
what you usually do is you back prop
three steps or four steps because you
need to keep all of this stuff in memory
if you want to back prop
um through time so
you you simply don't um also it gets
very noisy which is evident in these
older papers experiments right here as
they up the back prop through time you
can see this right here now compared to
Transformer Excel and look how
Transformer XL outperforms here on test
perplexity
um as as you increase the visible
context while training so just how much
context you see
and you get better as you up the back
prop Through Time number of steps but
you can see that as you go
this here actually gets better than
Transformer XL but then
um with more visible context it kind of
degrades I don't know exactly how to
interpret this
um you know really well but I can guess
maybe that's a property of uh too many
too much back prop through time is known
to be unstable
and they have also combined Transformer
XL here with backprop through time and
that turns out to work pretty great as
well the reason Transformer XL or things
like this haven't done back prop through
time is because they come from a time
when a Transformer XL just fit into
memory like it's like okay that's what
we can do we cannot do multiple of these
and now we can fit multiple of these
into the memory multiple steps and so we
can do the backdrop through time which
is linear in in scale
then obviously once you have trained
that let's say you train it on seven
steps which they do that's the maximum
they do right here seven segments once
you train it then on inferencing it over
thousands and thousands of segments is
not a problem anymore because if you
don't have to do back prop as you go
segment next segment next segment next
segment you can forget all of the old uh
all of the old memories and whatnot and
hidden States and you can go forever
essentially so
what's the the catch uh so they compare
along with like ooh scaling opt you know
if we if we go bigger how does it scale
it scales quadratically and we only
scale linearly yes of course this is
distinctively not the same thing right
it's an RNN it's not a Transformer
what it does is
it brings the power of Transformer like
the language understanding
um and combines that with an RNN so here
you can see as you as you train on more
segments for example let's say this
detect this one is a good example this
memorization if you train on one segment
boom as soon as you evaluate on two
segments you go down uh it simply
expects the it it solves the problem of
answering the question using attention
right and attention only works within
the segment so it can't go to two
segments because it doesn't even learn
how to use the memories
if you train on two segments you can see
uh you can you can go even to three and
then you start degrading so it learns a
little bit how to use that memory as you
go up you train with seven segments
which is I'm gonna guess is the highest
thing that that fits into their GPU
memory for training for back prop
um as you do that you can see then you
have a pretty stable algorithm and all
you did is you taught the algorithm of
detect the fact store it and then consid
and then don't change the memory until
you need to consider it right you've
taught that algorithm it's very
different from being able to you know
read an entire book and then draw
different draw different things from
that and ask questions about it like a
Transformer could if it really had the
full context size so
this is going to be applicable to very
distinctive tasks where you need to grab
like single facts a few single facts
that are dispersed in a very long text
that you otherwise don't need need to
consider 99 of it and you need to figure
that out somehow from that text and then
carry that over to the end maybe maybe
two facts as you see right here
so
the good thing of doing this is you can
bring this power of the Transformer to
do the language understanding within one
segment right you can make that really
powerful
um as for example birth and birth
derivatives are and you can use that to
detect the facts right they can be quite
complicated as long as they fit into one
segment and then you can use the RNN
part to sort of carry that over time
what you can do is like you know have
complex interdependencies and
interrelations and you need to consider
many things that are dispersed
throughout the text I hope it's a bit
clear what works and what doesn't work
they have nice investigations into how
the model uses the memory so if there is
no fact in the input you'd simply see
attention like diagonal attention
attention from the tokens to themselves
if there is a fact in the memory then
you see lots of attention to that to
those memory tokens so wherever that
fact is it will be stored into the
memory and then once you
once you
see the question or once the model sees
the question it's then going to consult
the memory so you're gonna see a lot of
attention on the on these memory tokens
right here so as it reads from the
memory again it's it's fairly cool for
the types of things that the these
authors here investigate and yeah this
plot over here to scale to a million
tokens
that it simply means it has learned that
algorithm and that algorithm
um once being learned with like seven
segments is now independent of the
length like it has robustly learned to
ignore the noise
um fairly fairly sure you could achieve
that with a bunch of other a bunch of
other techniques
um but this is one of them uh yeah so
that was it for shortly for for me
um again it is it is a cool paper and
the paper itself and the technical
report they're very clear what they're
doing but it's been a bit overhyped in
terms of what it means that was it let
me know in the comment please over hype
this video obviously I'll see you
bye-bye